foreign
[Music]
you were free to live and work in any
country you choose study abroad or sell
and buy Safe products on and offline
this is all thanks to the European
single Market which is 30 years old
the foundations of the single Market
were laid in the 1980s and in 1993 it
became a reality by then Europe had
almost completely harmonized standards
on a whole host of goods
foreign
until 2006 services such as postal
systems and transports still face
barriers the European Parliament adopted
numerous directives to make them more
easily available across the EU
but the 2008 economic and financial
crisis put the achievements of the
single Market at risk in 2010 Parliament
called for new momentum by focusing on
protecting consumers and improving the
market access of small businesses but
the single Market project is a project
for everyone for Citizens for consumers
for small Enterprise for large
Enterprise as well now what we need to
do is to really make it speak to those
people
2012 saw further moves to develop the
single Market members of parliament
called for a better more easily
accessible digital economy that wouldn't
discriminate against any customer or
business part of that was abolishing
roaming charges within the EU from June
2017.
in 2022 MEPS gave their green light to
the new digital markets and Digital
Services acts an unprecedented set of
rules to make the sector fair and
competitive
for a business user the competition will
work better for the consumer who buy
Goods they can feel more safe when
they're buying goods the digital Market
sector will introduce a new era of tech
legislation and in the future it will be
the big tech companies that will have to
prove to authorities that they abide by
the law
the single Market is playing an
increasingly important role in reaching
the eu's climate goals in 2022 MEPS
backed a common charger for small
electronic devices under pushing for a
right to repair Goods moves that will
increase products lifespans and reduce
e-waste
the war in Ukraine and the covid
pandemic show that the single Market can
be a powerful tool in times of Crisis
Parliament has welcomed proposals for an
emergency instrument to make it more
flexible and resilient
as we are in times of Crisis today we
also took a look at the single Market
always evolving through crises how
cooperation in the single Market is the
core and also the engine of European
integration
with the Boom in Internet shopping in
2023 Parliament is pushing for stricter
rules to increase the safety of products
sold both on and offline
If the product that you bought is
recalled you will be informed by email
if something goes wrong you will have
options for instance you want your
product to be replaced or you want to
have the product repaired or you want
your money back so you as a consumer
will have a choice
three decades after its birth the single
Market continues to evolve for the
benefit of 31 countries and 450 million
consumers the European Parliament is
shaping the path for safe diverse and
fair conditions on and offline
[Music]